Okay, okay, hello
everyone. In the previous video,
I shared with you about the
mode of production and its role.
In this video, I will
share with you about the productive forces and
relations of production. The video will cover
the productive forces and relations of
production. I will present it
concisely and use many examples
to make it easy for you to understand. If you find
this video helpful, please give
me a like, subscribe to the channel, and leave a
comment. Also,
remember, in the previous video, I talked about the
mode of production. The structure
and mode of production include the
unity between the productive forces at a
certain level and the corresponding relations of production,
forming the mode of production
in a certain period of
history. Now, let's first understand the
productive forces. Productive forces
are the sum of material
and spiritual elements that form the practical power to
transform the natural world according to the needs of
human survival and development.  The
structure of the productive forces includes
laborers and means of production.
Laborers are the human element,
possessing qualities such as health,
intelligence, professional skills,
and experience. They can be farmers, workers,
doctors, engineers, etc. The means of
production include labor tools and objects of labor.
Labor tools are those that
people use to act upon the objects of
labor to transform them
into products. Labor tools
include tools and means of
labor. For example, labor tools
are plows, hoes, harvesters, and tractors. Means of
labor are
roads, ports, and
transportation vehicles. Objects of labor are
those that people use tools
to act upon and create
products. Objects of labor
include things readily available in nature
such as land, forests, fish, and shrimp, or
processed objects such as electricity
or cement, as these are like
raw materials.  I'm creating a
product, and you guys are looking at the
overall picture again, right? The forces of
production include labor and
means of production. Within the means of production, there
are labor tools and objects of labor.
Regarding
labor, there are objects readily available in
nature and processed objects.
Now, let's take a general example
to make it easier to understand. For instance, a
farmer producing
food will use a
hoe or plow to till the
soil, making it loose and fertile for
planting, right? Then, they
buy fertilizer,
and after a period of time, they
harvest and sell. Now, let's
analyze it: the laborer here
is the farmer, and the means of
production include labor tools and
objects of labor. The plow and hoe are the
labor tools, while roads,
bridges, and
vehicles are the means of production.  Regarding the
means of labor, the
most easily observable object of labor
is Mother Earth, the plant, the flower,
and so on. Please note these points:
Firstly, among the factors that make up the
productive forces, people are the
most fundamental, decisive, and important factor.
Because humans not only create
tools and means of labor, devise
plans, and choose methods of labor, but
also directly use tools
and means of labor to create
production. Secondly, tools of labor are the
most dynamic element of the productive forces,
reflecting the ever-developing practical capacity of human beings.
Thirdly, in the
development of productive forces,
science plays an increasingly important role, gradually
becoming a direct cause of transformation in
both production and life. Science and
technology can be considered a characteristic of
modern productive forces.
Now, let's explore production relations.
Production relations are the
expression of the relationship between
people in the production process.
The relationship between
people is crucial for the
normal functioning of social production processes. For
example, consider
coal mining or construction.
If each person only performs a
separate task without coordination or
management, meaning there are no relationships between people,
then that collective
cannot produce material goods
effectively. Therefore, whether they like it or
not, people are compelled to
establish and maintain certain relationships
with each other in the production process to
ensure that production activities proceed
normally and efficiently. Production relations
include ownership relations over the means of
production in the organization and
management of production, and relations in the distribution of
labor products. Now, let's
analyze the first example:
ownership relations over the means of production,
such as tools,
means of labor, and objects of
labor. Who owns them
determines the socio-economic status of individuals.
Ownership relations regarding the means of
production are the most fundamental,
important, and characteristic relations of
production in society. The
remaining relations, for example, in a
confectionery company, the person who
owns the means of production—
machinery, raw materials, etc.—is the
owner, right? This person will have the
role of organizing, managing, and operating
production, and has the right to determine and
implement product distribution methods.
Conversely, anyone who doesn't own the means of
production—that is, without
money to buy machinery and equipment—to be the
owner must not only sell their
labor but also
receive less than the owner.
Secondly, regarding the relationship within the organization and
management of production, it means that within the organization, whoever
organizes, manages, and operates
production will directly impact the
process, scale, speed, and efficiency.
For example, a good owner or manager
will have a
rational and suitable method of organizing production for their employees, which is already very difficult.  The
quality and quantity of products
are also improved, and conversely, if the
boss or manager is
incompetent and unscientific, then the
subsequent production processes will not be
efficient. Instead, the relationship
in the distribution of labor products is the
division of the fruits of labor after the
production process among the workers,
and this directly affects
the interests of the producers; it
can promote or hinder the development
of production. For example, let's say
Ms. B's target is to produce 10 shirts in
one batch. If she produces fewer, her salary will be deducted,
but if she produces more than 10, she will be
rewarded. Therefore, she will be more enthusiastic about
working. If she works more or less, she will be
paid the price, and she won't be able to
work consistently. With rewards and punishments,
Ms. P's attitude towards work will be different.
I think this is getting too long. In the
next video, I will talk about the
law of production relations conforming to the
level of development of the productive forces.  I'm
sharing with
you about the forces of production and relations of
production, and if you find this video
helpful, please remember to give me
a like and leave a comment. If you're
interested, please subscribe to the channel and hit the
bell to receive notifications about the
latest videos. I will be releasing many videos on the
subject of the basic principles of
Marxism-Leninism. Now, goodbye and
see you in the next video!
[music]